[Music]
all right people we are live on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV and according to
the paperwork I'm still Dave Rubin and
it is Friday which means it's time for
another Friday
Extravaganza Roundtable Madness for you
brought to you by us uh joining me today
is a senior columnist at townhall.com
Kurt schlichter the CEO of Becker news
Kyle Becker and a contributing editor at
The Spectator and host of the fair
perspective podcast Melissa Chen Kurt
Kyle Melissa all Rubin report veterans
welcome back
thank you thank you Dave
all right it's good to see you guys uh
you know we were trying to figure out
what we wanted to do this week it's been
a lot of uh of Apple of China of Elon of
Kanye and then we thought all right
we're dropping Kanye we're going to
focus on uh mostly on Elon and apple and
free speech and all that good stuff so
of course the big thing this week uh
seems to be that the world is crashing
down on Elon as all he has done since he
has taken over Twitter is uh demanded
more or asked for or said that he's
gonna push for some more transparency
and it'll be a little more respectful of
uh Free Speech Apple doesn't seem to be
thrilled about that he had a meeting
with Tim Cook maybe it calmed down a
little bit and then of course there are
these uh images and videos coming out of
China related to their zero covid policy
and how apple is actually stopping the
people of China from sharing videos and
images so that the rest of the world can
see what's going on there so that's what
we're going to be focusing on today a I
want to start with the tweet from
Reuters a couple days ago because Elon
responded to a response to the tweet and
that's where it is going to set us up
today so here is a tweet from Reuters
Twitter not safer under Elon Musk says
former head of trust and safety and then
as it works on Twitter random people
respond to things so this is just a
random person that responded to that
tweet by the name of Eva Fox and said
Twitter has shown itself to be not safe
for the past 10 years and has lost users
trust the past team of trust and safety
is a disgrace so it doesn't have any
right to judge what is being done now
they had a chance but they sold their
souls they sold their souls to a
corporation and then here's where it got
interesting Elon responded to that and
said exactly the obvious reality as long
time users know is that Twitter has
failed in trust and safety for a very
long time and has interfered and in
elections Twitter 2.0 will be far more
effective transparent and even-handed
Kurt we kind of all knew that they
weren't that even-handed or fair or
anything like that but uh interfered in
elections I thought that was crazy
conspiracy stuff yeah that's what I was
told I was told the
perfectly fine unless they last occurred
in uh a year other than 2020.
um
you know it it it's kind of remarkable
the uh that we have a major news
organization like Reuters coming out
really against Free Speech because
there's there's no such thing as safety
safety is a nanny State word designed to
uh justify whatever political action
these folks want it's funny how safe the
the Venn diagram of safety and leftism
is a is a single Circle uh
and I I I like how Elon Musk just kind
of bowls through it see here's the thing
about Elon and I may write about this
next week in town hall he believed all
this stuff about liberalism and so did
you you believed you were a liberal guy
you thought oh Free Speech people get to
say what they want but that's not what a
lot of liberal guys really think a lot
of them think well free speech is great
until it stops being useful and then
it's unsafe or hateful or some other
weasel word used to justify silencing
the opposition and I I love
that we have Elon Musk I I coming out
and and blasting through it like uh you
know the old Kool-Aid guy in the uh
Saturday morning cartoons 40 years ago
Melissa uh putting aside the election
stuff for a second the idea that he's
getting rid of the trust and safety
people uh you know he went there's that
video of him in the closet getting rid
of the stay woke shirts I mean he is
purging what I think most people
watching this would believe are the the
bad aspects of the employees at Twitter
the people that were going out and about
and censoring and all that stuff I I
take it you see this as a positive huh
yeah I mean how many times in the last
few years have we seen friends of ours
commentators public commentators get
their accounts booted for reasons that
are very unclear right we we see that
with uh the trans debate if you debt
name somebody use the wrong pronoun so
you basically Express I mean Megan
Murphy expressed the radical idea that
you know there are just two genders and
she got banned from Twitter and you can
see kind of like the top-down decision
making process why why this is so toxic
to discourse and you know the truth is
there's only been this kind of landmines
when it comes to speech on on one side
and and I'm glad that elon's coming in
he's fixing it uh to Kurt's Point
actually the the other few words that
are now used there's there's free speech
there's hate speech but the other word
that they like to use also now is
misinformation or disinformation right
so that is just misinformation that is
covet misinformation and and you see
kind of Elon rolling back all these
things and allowing people to discuss
things again and I remember a time when
we weren't even allowed to talk about
the origins of of covid on a social
media platform and so I I'm really glad
that we're taking a look at we're able
to take a look with elong in charge
right now
um about what exactly went on the last
few years what worked with the
censorship policies because it was never
clear and what is he going to do moving
forward yeah Kyle do you think that he
is going to actually release the
internal documents like are we really
going to actually ever see oh these are
the people that actually were clicking
buttons or sliding sliders on
touchscreens that were making sure that
certain things weren't seen or that
certain things were seen or that we're
going into people's private DMS or
deleting uh tweets whatever it might be
because I always say it's not the stuff
we know about it's the stuff we don't
know about that I'm more worried about
but do you think he's really going to
open it up because to me that's the only
way we really get on the other side of
this by understanding how distorted our
reality became via these activists I
think Elon Musk has teased the Twitter
files uh and releasing this I don't I
think we might get a sanitized version
of it I don't think he will name names
and publicly accuse employees uh by name
um but I think one of the employees that
was cited in that Reuters article
ironically Joel Roth uh speak about a
failure of trust Reuters abandoned its
own editorial guidelines by failing to
to point out that this is a disgruntled
former employee who had made anti-trump
tweets and made Twitter more toxic
himself uh so the hypocrisy there uh by
Reuters is not surprising but they're
abandoning their own editorial
guidelines as are a lot of Publications
like the Washington Post uh the New York
Times that are complaining about Twitter
and Elon Musk so
um you know back to your point about
Elon Musk releasing the Twitter files I
think he gave us a little bit of a taste
with the election interference uh
confirmation that he gave and I think
that is uh real really alarming for me
because what you see with a lot of his
critics is that they tend to brush aside
the legitimate complaints of people uh
like Elon Musk uh and and they also fail
to call out his uh competitors like
Facebook they were involved in election
interference Zuckerberg personally
um you also see Tick Tock uh you know
basically a right hand of the CCP from
the very Beginnings tracking people uh
they're only complaining about Elon Musk
because he's giving conservatives uh a
voice on the platform and even playing
field and the left can't stand it to be
per you know perfectly honest yeah I
think it's not only the even playing
field thing but you know by
democratizing the blue check which he's
still figuring out some of the you know
how it's actually going to be rolled out
properly uh you know what it did was it
basically made all of the quote-unquote
journalists at Daily Beast and huffpo
all of these people that nobody really
followed that had 2 000 followers let's
say but they had the blue check they had
this fake influence and now he has made
that fake influence go away I think
that's what they're freaking out guys
we've got breaking news here a headline
from Breitbart
Jim Carrey has left Twitter my God Jim
Carrey has left Twitter Kurt how are you
going to stay on a platform without Jim
Carrey how are you going to do it I'm
trying to find the strength to move
forward Dave
um
wow
I you know sometimes you're just
speechless
um well okay so I'll I won't push you
that hard on the Jim Carrey thing but
this idea that suddenly these people
Alyssa Milano is freaking out and you
know all of these again the
quote-unquote journalists we're going to
leave Twitter and it's like no you're
not going to leave Twitter because you
guys don't have the wherewithal to build
anything yourself but that they didn't
care
three weeks ago when we were all getting
censored now they think this is the most
evil thing ever even though there's no
empirical evidence that hate has been
ramped up since he's taken over
I I wouldn't care if hate was ramped up
free speech is Free Speech
period you get to say things other
people don't like Now understand I want
to be real clear this is not hypocrisy
on their part some people are your
Twitter people are hypocrites no they're
not they don't believe in free speech
they are actively against it so is the
regime media they are actively for
censorship
and they're upset because Elon Musk came
along and bought
their BS line of reasoning
Melissa what do you think about that
because uh we have a lot of similar
friends or had some similar friends that
were you know thought of as more liberal
that suddenly really kind of are tacitly
or sometimes outwardly coming out for
censorship or not respecting views and
having that plurality of use it's
disappointing to say the least you know
firstly I haven't thought about Jim
Carrey in a long time so it's kind of
like there was this moment of
lightweight who is this person
um
yeah no I'm yes I imagine him coming out
of a rhino right now like that's just
you know the image but
but this whole thing about celebrities
kind of threatening to you know leave
Twitter it's it's it's so shallow and
it's so Hollow I mean Elisa Milano said
oh I'm gonna sell my Tesla I'm buying a
Volkswagen hilarious because obviously
what is the history of Volkswagen oh I
don't know he's awkward
um and and she's she's Tweeting or she's
still using an iPhone right but she's
grandiosely announcing that she's
leaving Twitter this iPhone the one that
she's using has all sorts of problems
Apple was found to have been using
sourcing parts of this iPhone from
xinjiang which is where they're they're
you know the uyghurs are being held and
and they're involved in like the
production of some of these parts
um and and even though the the White
House has passed the um the uyghur force
labor prevention act and she's still
using an iPhone and she's not
complaining about all these components
that go into this that actually affect
you know marginalized actually
marginalized people and so it just Rings
very Hollow to me all this kind of
posturing about like leaving Twitter
um and and with regard to what you're
saying about our friends who um you know
make huge announcements about leaving
Twitter and and are trending online for
uh you know for for days
um well I don't know about you but I I
kind of I kind of saw that coming you
know
um especially after a recent viral Clips
uh uh I know we're all talking about Sam
Harris viral Clips but but he you know
in his latest show he did explain why he
left and it's kind of the same argument
that we saw with the The Washington Post
headline that said the gates of hell are
now open with Elon at the helm and you
know Sam claims to to have to leave
because of just dealing with so much
hate on the website and is turning him
into this awful person he doesn't want
to you know he just doesn't want to be
part of it anymore and I fine that's a
legitimate reason to leave Twitter yeah
I mean I keep telling people as I've
gotten one or two Mean Tweets at me in
the Years you can just mute or block
people or you can actually not look at
your phone all day which is a really
fascinating thing I'm not a doctor but I
think most people can do that but let's
move from the celebrities for a minute
because we've got some info here from
the financial times just to show you
this isn't just about celebrities
leaving this place that that really
governments are truly afraid of what's
happening or breaking news the EU has
warned Elon Musk that Twitter could be
banned in Europe unless the billionaire
abides by its strict rules on content
moderation uh Kyle like they really
don't want that information we were
talking about getting leaked that's what
this is really about right it's not
about some frog kid making fun of Alyssa
Milano or Nancy Pelosi no uh Elon Musk
was on this call with his unelected uh
bureaucrat I think
furyton I don't think anybody's ever
heard of him before but he just kind of
popped up on the scene all of a sudden
and uh basically said Elon Musk has
gotta you know bend the knee to the EU
uh into Brussels to conform with all
their hate speech and uh as we saw you
know in a lot of these places uh you
know you can you can be arrested
potentially for certain kinds of hate
speech uh in some of these EU Nations
and uh I I think that what we're seeing
out of the EU is sort of uh you know a
Harbinger you know we wouldn't be
surprised if you see uh all of these uh
you know left loyalists like uh you know
Trudeau and all of these other uh
left-wing uh you know I mean we saw
today uh with uh macron who met with
with Biden he was criticizing Elon Musk
so I think like they're they're gonna
ramp up this campaign
um against him and uh you know they
don't have anything to say about his
competitors they don't have anything to
say about Apple and the gulags that
they're essentially running in zhengchao
city and Guangzhou and in some of these
places where we've seen violent worker
revolts in the last week and a half they
had nothing to say about that even Elon
Musk has had very little to say about
this uh you know I'm keeping an eye on
that and I hopefully he will speak up
after his pow-wow uh with Tim Cook
yesterday
um but you know they don't have anything
to say about ccp's gulags but if the
second that Elon Musk wants to you know
Grant amnesty to you know 11
000 conservative or otherwise banned
users
um you know that then the EU has
supposed concerns so uh right and and
yeah speaking speaking of the parts that
they don't want to talk about you know
uh there's suddenly all these articles
in the last week about how Twitter has a
child porn problem and Elon isn't doing
enough now I have no doubt that he's
doing something but let's let's say we
don't know exactly what he's doing yet
but nobody was writing these articles
for the last 10 years so it's only until
he took over that suddenly the
mainstream cares that there is a child
porn problem on there obviously that's a
huge problem and hopefully he can deal
with it but they're pretending to care
about it when they've had the last 10
years to to care and they haven't but I
want to shift a little bit to the to the
China portion of this but real quick on
the Apple part specifically a little
tweet thread here that involves Elon he
said that Apple has mostly this is a
couple days ago Apple has mostly stopped
advertising on Twitter do they hate free
speech in America then he followed up
Apple has also threatened to withhold
Twitter from its App Store but won't
tell us why and then he ended up going
to Apple headquarters he met with Tim
Cook thanks Tim Cook for taking me
around Apple's beautiful HQ which was
attached he had a video attached and he
said good conversation among other
things we resolved the misunderstanding
about Twitter potentially being removed
from the App Store Tim was clear that
Apple never considered doing so Kurt can
we trust that apple is going to stay on
the up and up here and that Tim Cook is
going to do the right thing and would be
willing to stand up to the pressure from
EU and wherever else he's going to get
pressure to boot Elon and Twitter well I
certainly hope so but the the real
pressure I think is actually coming from
the conservative it's not just Elon Musk
he's not afraid of Elon and I think he'd
happily throw Elon off the app store if
he uh could do it the the the
interesting change is what's happened
with the Republican Party and when this
uh threat to throw Elon Musk off of the
Apple Store came out a lot of
Republicans a lot of Fairly senior ones
said wait a minute wait a minute you
can't do this and if you do you're gonna
have a problem and we need more of that
we we need to get past is uh you know
I'm a republican not everybody is but uh
the Republican party needs to get past
the idea that we're some sort of uh
cheerleaders for every corporation uh
company and limited liability company
there is
we need to start standing up to these
guys and saying look if you're going to
get in a culture war with our
constituents then you're our enemy and
we're going to treat you that way you
can use your economic power we can use
our political power so if that's a game
you want to play go ahead and play and I
think Tim Cook wisely understood that
the uh Republican base which now holds
the house is not going to tolerate
uh being made war on by corporations
anymore so I I I I think if doing the
right thing isn't reasoned enough for
Tim Cook to act uh fear is and that's
fine
Melissa do you see that as a direct
extension of DeSantis ruling so uh
clearly and cleanly here in Florida I
mean he's been fighting apple and
Twitter and making comments about China
but showing people to to Kurt's point
that if you stand up and do the right
thing that people will follow you and it
seems to me that Republicans might be
getting that a little bit Kevin McCarthy
just the other day you know we're we're
not gonna go after Elon Musk even though
Biden said they'll try to find something
on him I mean that's that's Banana
Republic level stuff coming from the
Democrats
yeah um I I think we shouldn't forget
what happened to parlor
um I think you know in in thinking about
whether we should trust apple or not
um at the end of the day there it's not
just uh Twitter and apple Spotify and
and meta you know they have had
complaints about what's going on epic
games which is in a lawsuit with apple
uh has a lot of complaints about what's
going on with the with the App Store and
how much power Apple has as a platform
that built another platform on which
other platforms kind of rely on in this
ecosystem uh so I I appreciate the fact
that the Republicans are actually
pushing back and especially on the
inconsistency as you say you know the
the White House is is monitoring what's
going on with Twitter but giving Apple a
pass and and the fact that DeSantis is
pointing this out
um a lot of commentators are pointing
this out is is a good thing
Kyle I want to shift for a second
because uh let's move to the China part
and then I think you you connected
something here that's sort of breaking
at the moment but we've got a tweet here
from Whole Mars catalog uh Apple has
released a software update limiting the
use of airdrop in China in light of
recent protests airdrop was being used
by protesters to transmit info directly
from phone to phone bypassing the great
firewall of China so we covered this
over the last couple days and in essence
they updated everyone's app you know so
you're just sometimes if your phone's
just plugged in at night it gets the
update but what they didn't do which
they normally do is they tell you
exactly what's in the update and in this
case they did not tell you that they are
changing how airdrop works so all of
these people that are out there they're
sharing these videos that's how we're
seeing any of this stuff coming out of
China right now Apple clearly sided with
the communist government on this I take
it you're not that surprised
no I I think it's uh I think if you go a
little bit beyond uh the thinking that
apple is sort of complying with the ccps
the bands to really think that Apple
actually gets more than half of its
production out of its Chinese factories
including in Guangzhou City zhengchao
xinjiang uh all of these uh they have
basically I found camps that are run by
Foxconn and there have been uprisings in
these uh these camps in the last week
and a half two weeks and what you see is
that the covid lockdowns and the ccp's
measures sort of benefit Apple uh I've
looked inside some of these Foxconn
production City uh facilities it's very
dreary dark you know they're all bunked
together I mean it's like the worst
dormitory even imagine yeah it's and so
the thing is there's a there's sort of a
quid pro quo going on between Apple and
CCP where CCP uh basically all of their
measures are in indirectly benefiting
apple and it's product it's basically
he's kind of slave labor type camps
there and they have a long history of
cooperating with CCP going back to 2017.
so they limited the vpns that can be
used on the Apple phones in China they
also limited some privacy features last
year and this November 9th update they
changed the airdrop that you were
talking about to where it basically
expired after 10 minutes uh you couldn't
use it after that point so uh I think
that it's really what you're looking at
is they are very heavily influenced by
Chinese production and the Chinese
market which has grown I think it's up
to 16 percent of the market share in to
this year so uh I think that's a way to
look at it is that that the ccp's
policies are kind of a synthesis of this
kind of globalist corporatism uh that is
benefiting companies like apple and so I
think that what the Republicans need to
do is stand up for American values
demand that they comply with uh our
values in our country like free speech
and and basically coerce them and use
the power of government or Apple's going
to continue to be a threat to uh
citizens all over the over all over the
world essentially yeah and look you you
can call me a conspiracy theorist but I
think a guy like Justin Trudeau is
watching that happening in China right
now and despite the fact that he's
saying all the right things we know what
he did to his truckers and the
protesters when they wanted to open up
Canada and I think he's watching going
boy it's possible if they uprise against
me again that Apple will help me shut
down their phones that that would be
pretty sweet like they're running a
little test over there but uh Kyle real
quick can you can you uh elaborate on
what you sent us right before the show
this uh this interview with Tim Cook
that just broke because it's pretty uh
telling of everything that's going on
here right I was keeping an eye on Tim
Cook uh you know any news with him being
confronted by reporters and Hillary
Vaughn over at Fox Business essentially
confronted uh you know and was there
when uh Tim Cook was asked three
different questions do you support the
Chinese people's right to protest
do you have any reaction to the factory
workers that were beaten and detained
for protesting coveted lockdowns
do you regret restricting airdrop access
that protesters used to evade
surveillance from the Chinese government
do you think it's problematic to do
business with the Communist Chinese
party when they suppress human rights
he didn't even respond when he said do
you support the Chinese people's right
to protest uh and then do you regret
restricting the airdrop uh access that
protesters use to evade surveillance
from Chinese government uh completely
silent
um I I think that really this shows that
he is feels like he is under duressed to
kowtow to the CCP uh and he doesn't want
to criticize them and you know look uh
it is not it goes beyond corporations in
this country we're seeing politicians
high level and officials we saw the dod
spocks the other day was asked at a
press conference uh about this and he
said this the protesters speak for
themselves he couldn't stand with them
uh it was really unbelievable
um you know so I think like we're seeing
the elites whether they're corporatists
uh or you know CEOs uh you know in our
defense department they're on the same
page they're basically on the same page
with Connie's Channel as we saw and not
not to get too far foot but we saw
recently with the geofence data uh on
January 6 the FBI using NSA databases to
track U.S citizens uh they're using see
the Chinese style surveillance in the US
right now I think we've seen some recent
articles that that show that
um so right and and literally millions
of people in the United States have tick
tock on their phone which we know is a
spy up and Eric swalwell uh slept with
the Chinese spy everyone knows that too
and he's still in Congress Melissa do we
have any leverage over China to do
anything about this whether it's
influencing Apple to you know help the
protesters or at least not harm the
protesters or anything else maybe
related to Taiwan or anything or or are
we just like we're bit players in
China's game almost at some level
well one one of the drawbacks of
globalization that we don't talk about
is that when um you know when our
markets were interlinked it became
really hard for our country and and
companies in our free country to
actually stand up for value for its
values and we saw that with the NBA and
it was so on such Stark display and what
we have instead is that the instead of
exporting our model of you know
political freedom to China it was the
other way around they exported their
brand of censorship and their way of
life almost we saw that with lockdowns
they exported it to the rest of the
world uh so you know in terms of
Leverage What what what can we do uh at
the end of the day you know decoupling
is is probably the best thing to do it
looks like our calculus of actually
enriching China through trade and
economic integration was a bit of a
mistake and and you are seeing that
Biden has actually rolled forward all of
Trump's policy is on China and nothing
has been rolled back and in fact he's
doubling down on more so if you look at
the chips act that is being passed that
has already actually been passed so that
that's probably our best leverage right
now is to decouple and assert ourselves
I mean if you notice it's the CEOs and
and the companies that are not involved
with China that can actually speak
honestly about the issue right and so
that's telling us something if you want
to stand up for your values you have to
have no economic interest in the country
who you want to speak honestly about you
are giving me a segue like a pro because
speaking of speaking honestly and with
Clarity and doing the right thing and
not being beholden to other countries
here's Ron DeSantis from the free state
of Florida the CCP they have been posing
the zero covid lockdown policies they've
been doing it on and off for three years
and you have people in China that are
really engaged in a noble effort to
protest which is basically leninous rule
so what is Apple doing with that they
are limiting the airdrop function of the
protesters so they are serving basically
as a vassal to the Chinese Communist
party they exercise more Authority in
some respects than even some governments
do and they're using their authority to
protect the CCP uh we'll also try to
limit speech here in the United States
Kurt I always say on the show it's so
refreshing When someone tells the truth
because it's like the truth is supposed
to be heard it's supposed to be spoken
so and we and it's so rare these days
that when you hear it it's like this
like exhale
um we're never going to get that kind of
clarity out of this Administration are
we when it comes to China or pretty much
anything of course not they're they're
totally in Hawk to China
remarkable
how an American government actually
covers for all these dictatorships
whether it's Iran or China
uh or Venezuela which can now pump oil
while Americans can't it's almost as if
they were on the other side and I I look
at this and I'm thinking what would they
be doing different if they were actively
anti-American and I really can't think
of anything making excuse for China the
most thorough going and uh
evil dictatorship currently on Earth
maybe North Korea gives it a run for its
money
it's it it's astonishing
way they've obeyed have abandoned all
our key principles Dave like free speech
I mean you you would think that at the
very least they're going to stand up for
the First Amendment
and the concept behind it but no they're
against it they're actively against free
speech for Americans and they side with
foreign dictators to make that happen
that's why that's why I keep yeah well
that's why I keep bringing up this point
from a couple weeks ago when Biden had
that he literally had a tick tocker
conference at the white house so they
bring in Chinese spyware and then one of
them asks him what are you going to do
about Elon Musk and he said we don't
know that he's done anything wrong but
we'll look I mean it's the most crazy
Kabuki theater type stuff you could
imagine but for those people that are
watching this that aren't sure what's
going on in China there's a gajillion
videos despite what Apple's doing with
airdrop out there so we've got about a
minute's worth of compilation for you
[Music]
[ __ ]
yourself
[Applause]
[Applause]
are you doing
I mean it's just unbelievable it's like
half of what was happening in Canada
over the summer throwing a little squid
games and a couple other dystopian
movies and and that's what you've got
um Melissa obviously we're not we're I
think we're all in agreement the U.S
isn't going to do much about this but do
the Chinese people have a chance like is
there any chance they can create any
sort of change themselves or is this
going to sort of be like what's going on
in Iran it's like it kind of happens for
a while and then it dies down and the
regime never changes
um I'm not optimistic about about any
change per se but you know this is
significant what what has happened over
the weekend with these protests this is
the largest display of public Defiance
against the regime since Tiananmen
Square protest in 1989.
um and to see such widespread Civil
Disobedience at the same time is is
quite striking in China in a place like
China
um what I what I will say is that
because these protests actually very
targeted what the people want is to get
out of this Perpetual lockdown situation
I mean they are frustrated in xinjiang
for example they had been in lockdown
for 100 days straight and and many of
these cities like Beijing Shanghai
people are starving I mean in in the
land of abundance right supposedly the
Chinese Communist Party pulled so many
people out of poverty they're all middle
class and wealthy now people are
actually starving because of lockdowns
people have died because of lockdowns as
we saw in the fire that killed some
people so people are frustrated they
have the that's the end of what they can
tolerate and they're they're rising up
but at the end of the day the Chinese
state power and surveillance apparatus
is so perfected I mean mean you you need
a coat to even travel to you know to a
certain place and into certain buildings
and if you don't scan that code you're
not going to be allowed in and they can
use this kind of technology that was
originally meant for controlling the
epidemic to actually curtail movement
and and we saw that an example of this
actually last summer when when they were
able to prevent protests for a bank run
um using the the actual software that
was meant to monitor the infections so I
I'm not optimistic about any kind of
higher up kind of change you know in
terms of toppling the government in
terms of challenging the regime's whole
and Power
that's not gonna happen China is is is
is still stable in that sense because of
of the the way it's structured but I
think that what we will see is probably
loosening up a covert restrictions
that's probably the best case scenario
for for the Chinese people Kyle is it is
it nuts or obvious that you know two
years ago when we were all being forced
to you know have covid passes on our
phones or whatever else I never did it
for the record but when they wanted to
force us all to do that and a whole
bunch of crazy right-wing people on
Twitter many of whom got banned were
saying that this was really to Institute
a social credit system which in essence
is what Melissa is talking about it's
like yeah it probably is on the way here
because kovid was breaking in China
before 2020 before it hit America and
you know it'll probably uh break this
way when it comes to some some of this
Tech stuff
we have to kind of look at for me how uh
it's so many coincidences that defy
belief first of all the SARS cov2 virus
it almost certainly looks to be man-made
according to latest research
peer-reviewed research that says that
they found the fingerprint and they can
now synthesize or re-synthesize uh the
sarsko V2 virus and it did break before
December 2019 it looks somewhere in that
period where it became public knowledge
so what we have now and I just looked at
the global serial prevalence data and uh
the the Sarah prevalence data in the
United States we have almost nearly
Universal exposure to sarsko V2 now if
you look it's somewhere between 97 and
99 in the US uh according to the CDC
Sarah Hub uh their serial trackers
around the globe that show very similar
rates so we have this Universal almost
omnipresent virus that can be used as an
excuse for lockdowns uh the QR Code
system that Melissa was talking about
where they can just give you a red code
and you can't get in uh to where you
need to be at you can restrict your
freedom of travel
um so you have that and you look at the
fact that even if you take the highest
estimates of 6.6 million fatalities with
covid uh that's 99.9 uh
survival rate at this point and I think
it will project to be about 99.9 or less
even giving the benefit of the doubt on
the mortality rate so the fact that the
Western societies were so quick to turn
their societies upside down kill small
businesses prevent people from seeing uh
loved ones in the hospital going to
funerals shutting down kids sports uh
all of these things the masks in the
schools we turn this upside down it
shows a collapse of our values at the
philosophical level our universities our
education system is a rot they are not
if we were a strong country we would
look at China and what they did with
their virus as an attack on us as an
invasion instead we're we're sort of
just like oh let's look at you know like
fauci let's look at China as a model uh
you know we just had the the deposition
from him uh last week The Seven Hour
deposition in that lawsuit and and it
revealed that he looked at China as a
model him and his advisors to go with
you know and I know recently two-faced
fauci sort of disavowed or played it
down like oh the Draconian lockdowns in
China went too far oh really well they
went too far in the U.S too because it
violated our civil liberties uh and and
all of this could have been left between
doctors and patients like Ron DeSantis
did for the most part in Florida
um you know very early on he he sort of
you know pivoted to doing what he should
what I thought should have been done by
every governor in the country protect
the nursing homes protect the vulnerable
and then just sort of manage it the best
you can instead we got people like fauci
you know and he's bail in town now and
you know probably a wise decision on his
part but you know these these officials
need to be held accountable for uh their
ties to China that needs to be exposed
and I think Rand Paul will will look
into that soon and also held accountable
for fraud that they they knowingly
committed against us in the public yeah
I mean unfortunately I think we all know
that uh fauci's not gonna end up in jail
and wolenski's not going to get fired
and that these people who lied about
everything and that's another reason
they want Elon to get you know not have
Twitter it's because we can keep showing
the videos of fauci saying I'm not for
lockdowns I am for lockdowns masks don't
work you better double mask vaccines you
won't get or transmit covid uh that was
Joe Biden next thing you know of course
you do uh
Kurt bring us home here uh you live in
California
I live in the Free State of Florida I'm
pretty confident between Ron DeSantis
and the apparatus in this state and and
the spirit of the people that we will
fight as much as we possibly can and
that this is the blueprint for a free
America and a free world you live in the
Stark opposite place so when are you
moving here
that's a great question Dave and uh uh
it's literally one that I end up talking
about every single day with people look
I I like California I moved here when I
when uh Ronald Reagan was governor in
1972 I was just a little kid and uh
California was always about opportunity
about sunshine which you can see behind
me palm trees it was a place of
opportunity and that's not true today
uh I'd like to think it's going to get
better but here's the problem with this
kind of socialist nightmare there's no
bottom it never gets so bad where they
look at each other and go you know maybe
we've been on the wrong track the only
answer is to double down to give them
more power and more of your money
um we'll see what happens
uh you know I have a little bit of Hope
for California in the recent election we
want a couple uh seats that weren't
necessarily expected and there are
people with common sense here but a lot
of you know a lot of my conservative
friends like yourself have left I I
literally have a handful of conservative
friends left in California the rest of
the people seem to be happy and
wallowing in their uh uh misery of
homelessness crime and high taxes it's
kind of sad to see Kurt I saw you a
couple weeks ago at the Hard Rock Hotel
in Hollywood Florida you were smiling
you were happy you were drinking tequila
you hadn't smiled in months you told me
and uh well I guess as Jerry said to
George good luck with all of that you
know that's all I that's all I could say
Melissa is also in California but at
least you bounce around a lot so I don't
really consider you trapped there true
yeah
guys thank you for joining me on this
Friday I'm going to finish up for a
moment without you but have a great
weekend and uh I'll have you guys back
soon
happy weekend thanks Dave
all right people uh that is another week
of shows and uh this was this was an
interesting week I I hope that uh even
though we talked an awful lot about the
Twitter thing and an awful lot about the
Apple thing and the censorship thing uh
I hope that and some of it probably was
a bit repetitive I hope that you see why
it's so important to hit it we gotta
keep hitting it over and over and over
again so that when guys like Ron
DeSantis fight they know they're backed
with people so that when Kevin McCarthy
uh when he fights and hopefully he'll be
the leader of the Congress when he
fights he'll know that the people have
his back and that enough of us will will
be wise to the game we don't want the
censorship anymore we understand that uh
Speech it's messy and people might say
mean things but we have to get a little
bit closer to the truth one of the
reasons people are so bananas and so
many people suffered from Trump
Arrangement syndrome and covid
Arrangement syndrome and everything else
is because social media was supposed to
be a mirror that we could look at and
and
get an honest reflection of reality to
and it became a fun house mirror and I
think hopefully if Elon releases some of
this stuff we will get a sense of boy it
was manipulated nobody was really into
this crazy woke stuff and the gender
stuff and they did you know do whatever
they did with elections and Hunter Biden
laptop and all those things and then the
truth
I don't think I'm the first way to say
this the truth will set us free you got
it uh anyway have a great weekend guys
we got a big interview coming next week
that I'm super psyched for and uh lots
of good stuff happening if you want to
play along during the show join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and I will see
you oh Monday we're doing a delayed show
right I believe Monday is going to be a
little bit in the afternoon if I'm not
mistaken no show Monday no I think we're
doing a delayed show I don't know but
we're not editing this out because we're
gonna see what happens it will
definitely not be at 11 o'clock I think
it's a little bit later in the day
you're both looking at me like I'm crazy
Tuesday no show Monday that's it no show
well I guess I've been well who knows
it'll be a surprise see you whenever